I'm excited. Let's get some DNA out of this guy.
>> Well hold on Lauren before we actually get
DNA from Matt, we need to take a couple
of other steps. And the key thing is before
we proceed and get DNA from Matt, he needs to
make sure he's comfortable with how his DNA and
genetic information will be used by 23andMe. So you
can read the terms of service, and understand how
that information will be used, and make that decision on
his own.
>> Well, this sounds like I also probably at some
point need to provide some consent for other services as well.
>> Well, that's true because in all
research, a really important component is informed
consent, where the person who's involved in
it understands the risks and benefits of participation.
>> So yes, Matt you like all 23andMe
customers, will get to choose whether you want to
take part in research, and have your genetic information
be used for research, and your other personal information.
And so you get to decide whether you're going to consent use of your information
>> Well I know that informed consent is a
very important aspect of medicine and research today. So, if
you're interested in learning more about it. You can
visit the American Medical Association and search for Informed Consent.